dr gears was having another boring day
at the scp foundation and that was
exactly how he liked it he treated
himself to a cup of decaf black coffee
no cream no sugar a simple plain donut
and an apple the breakfast of champions
to him at least his duties today were
ones he'd overseen so many times before
watching his ever-rotating legion of
subordinates shove various items into
scp-914 the clockworks just to see what
on earth would happen this machine had
the ability to transmute matter in a
variety of fashions depending on the
input selection whether rough coarse
one-to-one fine or even very fine they
tested everything from dr gears watch to
a chimp which as we all know resulted in
the beloved hyper-intelligent chimp
scientist dr bobo there were in fact
such extensive testing records for
scp-914
that dr gears had started taking an
uncharacteristic hands-off approach to
testing as long as the researchers
working under him were reasonably sure
that the results of their testing
wouldn't result in a containment breach
a fundamental alteration of consensus
reality or some massive loss of life
they could just go ahead with whatever
dumb little experiment their heart
desired this however would turn out to
be a way longer leash than dr gears ever
should have given to the kind of weirdos
who work at the scp foundation there had
been certain let's say
incidents in the past that have proved
members of the scp foundation aren't
above using anomalies inappropriately
for their own personal enjoyment there
was of course the incident with
scp-662 the butler's hand bell and the
supernatural butler it summons mr deeds
during the early stages of testing dr
mirth under the guise of experimentation
made mr deeds make him tea wash his car
cut his hair and even do his laundry dr
mirth was given a stern talking to by
the o5 council for this abuse of power
good job o5 council it's not like you
ever use anomalies for your own benefit
um
let's move on nothing to see here folks
speaking of people working for the
foundation using anomalies
inappropriately who could forget the
extremely uncomfortable incident
involving scp-137
a real toy this anomaly has the ability
to become a real-life version of any toy
brought into its vicinity from the
masters of the universe to barbie in her
dream house but one researcher was
hiding a horrifying secret he was a
brony and that's why he sneaked a
twilight sparkle toy into the testing
chamber so he could have a conversation
with his favorite my little pony
character which all in attendance agreed
just had incredibly rancid vibes through
and through
and that brings us back to today dr
gears deciding to let his subordinate
researchers throw pretty much anything
into the clockworks as long as it was
unlikely to cause physical harm and
leaving this metaphorical door open
allowed people like dr siegel to step
through you see while dr siegel was
considered by most to be an incredibly
diligent and hardworking junior
researcher he did have one vice in his
downtime
he was a card-carrying furry and we're
not just talking about a guy who watched
disney's zootopia a few too many times
he had his own
fursona a wolf if you were curious i
personally wasn't he attended cons for
fellow furries semi-frequently and even
had his own expensive custom high-end
fursuit as such there was one scp he
found particularly interesting scp-1470
also known as mal-o version 1.0.0
an anomalous mobile app with some
extremely strange properties if you
access it on an app store of your choice
you'll encounter an image of a strange
skull-headed canine creature with the
following iconic description malo
version
1.0.0 free reviews zero description
never settle for those awkward feelings
of being alone ever again mao is an
exciting and interactive experience that
will keep you engaged and intrigued the
anxiety of social situations can be
nerve-racking but after just a few hours
of mao
you will soon forget all about those
painful emotions of disappointment be
part of the new craze that is so quickly
becoming the next social substitute
remember the more you participate the
more mal-o will engage you your
experience is completely up to you
absolutely no ads enjoy
dr siegel was certainly eager to forget
all his painful emotions of
disappointment and embrace the new
social substitute but he'd read all the
documents and seen all the pictures on
the file those who download the malo app
will be texted a series of photos
becoming closer to home over time both
literally and figuratively which show
the strange creature known as mal-o
getting closer and closer for some this
would be a complete nightmare for those
inclined in the direction of dr siegel
it would be a dream come true there was
only one issue they were just pictures
but dr siegel didn't get a job at the
scp foundation by having a lack of
intelligence he'd very quickly figured
out a potential solution to the digital
barrier between him and his canine crush
he'd buy a burner phone download the
malo app onto it and put the resulting
infected device directly into the
clockworks it was one of the best ideas
he'd ever had in his own humble opinion
but of course it would all be about
selecting the right setting on rough the
most likely result would be the phone
itself just being transformed into a
pile of broken glass metal and a variety
of conflict minerals reduced to dust on
course the result would likely be the
metal chassis of the phone the front
glass panel and a neatly arranged
interior gutted from within on one to
one considering he'd bought a slightly
older cheaper model of samsung's
smartphone he'd probably get the malo
app on an iphone and on fine perhaps the
best he could hope for was getting mal-o
version
2.0.0 which may have some minor
improvement like the pictures appearing
twice as fast as they would with the
normal app experience dr siegel knew
that the only other option that could
potentially bring malo into the real
world was the highly unpredictable very
fine option which would either produce
the desired result or cause something
utterly horrifying to happen but at the
end of the day dr siegel thought to
himself isn't anything worth having also
worth incurring a little risk who dares
wins after all right he downloaded the
fateful app and made his way into the
testing area for scp-914
he booked the slot so it was all
official but he still felt his heart
racing as he put the infected phone into
the input chamber he set the control
panel to very fine exactly as planned
and activated the machine cogs twisted
and churned engines rumbled and
sputtered pipes wriggled and hissed it
was clear that something was going on
here when the process was complete and
the output chamber opened with a
billowing carpet of steam dr siegel
could barely contain his excitement he
hoped that malo would come strolling out
of the smoke like darth vader and star
wars a new hope so you can only imagine
his extreme disappointment when the
chamber was completely empty it didn't
make sense he thought everything through
how could the result possibly be so
anti-climactic this had gone from one of
the most exciting days of his life to
the most depressing dr siegel sighed and
decided to call it quits heading out of
the test chamber having no idea what
he'd just unleashed onto the foundation
across the site dr alto clef one of the
foundation's most infamous researchers
was polishing his favorite shotgun in
his office he was whistling a cheerful
tune to himself just loving life when he
heard some strange rustling by the door
he turned around on his swivel chair
just to make sure it wasn't dr bright
putting another bucket of battery acid
on top of his door as a quote fun
harmless prank instead he was shocked to
see mal oh an actual physical malo
standing in his doorway grinning for a
moment clef was too shocked to even
react this didn't make any kind of sense
but when mal o gave him a cheeky wink he
immediately loaded his shotgun and fired
blowing away a chunk of his own doorway
but sadly for him by that time malo had
already darted away intent on causing
mischief elsewhere it's favorite pastime
dr cleff was still wondering whether
that rascal dr bright was somehow behind
this fiasco
but he was not because he was actually
about to become mal-o's next victim in
its ruthless reign of mild to moderate
inconvenience dr bright was swanning
around the break room with his favorite
morning snack a coffee with extra cream
and a danish from his favorite bakery in
town he was looking forward to enjoying
these two simple pleasures in his
otherwise incredibly stressful life but
little did the poor doctor know tragedy
was about to strike and nothing would
ever be the same just as the immortal
doctor was about to disembark from the
room mal-o appeared right in front of
him giving him the mild shock of his
life it was such a surprising occurrence
in fact that he momentarily lost his
grip on his coffee mug and his danish
causing both to tumble to the ground the
mug shattered and the danish splattered
by the time dr bright looked up mal oh
was already gone just like his breakfast
snack dr bright fell to his knees and
screamed why
up to an indifferent break room ceiling
but mal oh was just getting started dr
kane patho's crow was on his way from
his kennel
we mean his private quarters to the soul
extractor when mal-o suddenly manifested
in front of him this resulted in a brief
barking match between the two for
dominance over that particular hallway
which ended in mal-o d-manifesting to
bother someone else which technically
made dr crowe the winner though crow
himself resented ever being forced to
act like a mere mutt how he began to
wonder had malo escaped its app and
begun to harass the real world this
would warrant further investigation malo
continued its rampage of irritation
across the site intended to leave no
stone of frustration unturned and it
wasn't just the foundation staff it
intended to freak out it was just as
eager to go and bother its fellow
anomalies now that it had access to the
meat space yes that is a real term we're
not just being weird and gross we
promise over in the cell of scp-173 the
sculpture three members of d-class
personnel were cleaning up the homicidal
creatures blood and poop they were
engaged in the standard procedure one of
them mopped while the other two kept a
close eye on
scp-173 to keep it frozen in place
that's when maul o popped into the cell
behind them for a split second before
disappearing scaring the living hell out
of all three of them though the fright
was of course secondary to the fact that
the second they looked away
scp-173 snapped all three of their necks
oops may have gone a little too far on
that one hey mellow but this newly
embodied burdensome beast was just
getting started friends no anomaly was
safe from its new antics next it
appeared in front of scp-682's acid tank
and made rude faces at the hateful
creature from the other side of the
glass this only served to sour the
creature's already utterly horrific mood
it thrashed around in the chamber
attempting to get out and perform an act
of great violence but by that time maul
o was already long gone and scp-682 was
left grumbling in immense frustration
scp-049 the plague doctor was having
another very boring day he'd been denied
his animal cadaver test subjects for
several days as a disciplinary measure
after the latest incident and as such he
was finding other ways to pass the time
today he was meticulously removing each
piece of medical equipment polishing
them and putting them in a neat line on
his desk in his containment chamber
scalpels forceps speculums bone saws all
wonderful shiny and pristine the plague
doctor found it to be an incredibly
calming activity so of course mal o
couldn't just let him be the
cantankerous canine driven mad by the
power of suddenly being able to interact
with the world physically manifested in
the middle of the containment chamber
and used its tail to knock all the
meticulously arranged medical equipment
onto the ground with a thunderous
clatter the plague doctor devastated
lifted both of his hands to his beak and
yelled sacre blue in horror in that same
instant malo once again disappeared
leaving the tragic doctor to start from
scratch it was a serious setback on an
otherwise lovely day curse you strange
dog creature he thought to himself all
bending over to pick up the pieces curse
you and your entire bloodline a group of
hardcore mobile task force members was
engaged in the comically manly activity
of playing poker while smoking in the
barracks and before you judge them for
that remember that if your job was as
stressful as being a member of a mobile
task force you'd probably smoke too but
their job was about to get a little more
stressful when malo suddenly
materialized and gave the poker table a
sharp kick sending the towers of poker
chips and decks of cards all over the
place before disappearing without a
trace yet again it completely ruined
their game one of the more junior
members asked should we have uh done
something about that a more senior
operative shook his head and said well
we'll do something when we get the
official call from up top until then uh
let's reshuffle the deck in the site 19
cafeteria dr agatha wright was preparing
to eat a delicious salad that she'd been
waiting all day to enjoy as we've often
established working at the scp
foundation can be an immensely stressful
job so you need to take the small joys
where you can get them for dr rights
this delicious premium salad that she'd
bought from harris teeter earlier in
that day was indeed a joy she even got a
fancy vinaigrette dressing for the
occasion before she took the first bite
she noticed scp-073
kane approaching dr wright smiled and
gave him a polite nod kane waved back
that our dear viewers is when tragedy
struck malo suddenly manifested in front
of kane propping out one of its candid
legs right in front of where the hapless
anomaly was walking by the time kane
began to trip and fall over mal o had
already vanished but it was too late
kane kept falling forward until one of
his metal hands landed right into the
bowl that contained dr wright's salad
due to his anomalous abilities the salad
immediately withered away into nasty
dead nothingness dr wrights began to cry
as kane who felt profoundly guilty tried
his best to apologize truly nobody in
sight 19 was safe mal-o popped up behind
iris and ruined all of her photos mal-o
popped up behind the immortal hitler
clone in his cell and gave him a good
kick in the rear mal-o even popped up
right behind scp-343
also known as god who smugly replied i
knew you were going to do that my son
needless to say it had been one hell of
a day dr siegel completely ignorant to
the chaos his actions had caused around
the sight had cried in the bathroom for
40 minutes out of sheer disappointment
he barely been able to focus on the rest
of his duties for the day on account of
being severely bummed out this was a day
he'd been looking forward to for so long
and it all had been for nothing that
evening he was driving home on the
highway listening to sad songs on the
radio thinking about the fact he'd
probably just crack open a beer and get
some sleep when he got home he sighed
again and looked up to adjust his
rear-view mirror when he saw a skeletal
face with huge white eyes staring at him
in the reflection a quick almost
reflexive turn revealed a huge black
figure with a canine skull for a face
was indeed just sitting in his back seat
watching him it was so shocking that he
immediately veered off the road and
crashed his car into the concrete
divider in the middle of the road
breaking his nose and collarbone in the
process really a perfect cherry on top
for this kind of day dr siegel was
sitting in the hospital not long after
that with a cast around his upper body
this was also where he received a
bouquet of flowers from dr gears with an
attached note saying he was put on
three-month disciplinary leave for the
irresponsible use of scp-914
dr siegel looked up and saw that mal-o
was peering around the corner at him
with its dead white eyes its fang lined
ma twisted into a permanent ominous grin
at this point dr siegel realized that
being chased around constantly by a
demonic skull-faced anomaly in real life
wasn't nearly as whimsical as he
expected it would be in hindsight that
probably should have been obvious
shouldn't it though please let us know
if you'd like mal o to stalk you in real
life in the comments below you bunch of
weirdos now go check out
scp-1471 mal-o version 1.0.0 and scp-914
what did you put in it for more on
today's unique and strange anomalies